corona risiko familienfeier ärzte
fordern klare regeln für private partys
die infektionsgefahr dort sei zu hoch
frankreich verschärft seine regeln ab
september geht die masken pflicht
überall am arbeitsplatz und damit auch
in büros und attacken gegen präsident
trump die demokraten start mit einem
virtuellen parteitag in die heiße phase
des us wahlkampfs
nachrichten nicht daran dass leute mit
christian sievers guten abend und
herzlichen dank dass sie bei uns sind
das schon mal vorweg in den kommenden
zwanzig minuten der nachrichtenüberblick
natürlich auch mit dem sport und mit
rudi cerne hallo guten abend die sorgen
davor dass die krone situation in
deutschland wieder schwierig wird zu
beherrschen nehmen zu
bundeskanzlerin angela merkel fordert
heute von den behörden die geltenden
regeln auch konsequent durchzusetzen
zeit für neue beschränkungen sei noch
nicht aber aus ihrer sicht auch keine
zeit für weitere lockerungen die zahlen
steigen weiter die gemeldeten
neuinfektionen liegen aktuell bei 1170
im durchschnitt der letzten sieben tage
gestern waren es noch 1100 in den fokus
geraten immer mehr feiern von familien
und im freundeskreis denn dort gibt es
aktuell besonders viele ansteckungen
noten linus die überreste einer privaten
geburtstagsparty und die sorge vor einer
massenhaften ansteckung rund 100
menschen feierten am wochenende fröhlich
zusammen
jetzt ist klar eine war positiv das war
eine private durchgeführt die feier der
gesetzgeber hat die möglichkeit
geschaffen dass so etwas möglich ist und
das ist genutzt waren damit sein uns als
kommune die hände gebunden aber
letztendlich kaum jemand diese
möglichkeiten nutzen das beschauliche
bodenwöhr in der oberpfalz hatte zuletzt
niedrige infektionszahlen doch nun
mussten alle geburtstagsgäste in
quarantäne der korona positive mann war
erst am tag vor der partie aus italien
zurückgekehrt das kein risikogebiet ist
größere feste gelten als mögliche
spender ereignisse bei denen ein
infizierter viele andere ansteckt vor
allem wenn wieder mehr in geschlossenen
räumen gefeiert wird wie im herbst bei
kühleren temperaturen dafür fordern
ärzte bundesweite und schärfere regeln
es ist wichtig dass wir konzepte haben
für geschlossene räume
denn natürlich können wir jetzt uns noch
auch zu kleineren feiern draußen treffen
das wird dann nicht mehr gehen so dass
auch wieder größere zusammenkünfte in
geschlossenen räumen stattfindet das und
lüftungskonzept ganz wichtig und es ist
am ende auch wichtig obergrenzen
festzulegen
eine feste zahl nennt sie nichts sagt
nur das risiko sei 100 teilnehmern
deutlich höher als bei 20 derzeit am
strengsten bayern sachsen und
schleswig-holstein höchstens 100
teilnehmer sind erlaubt besonders
großzügig niedersachsen hamburg
mecklenburg-vorpommern berlin baden
württemberg maximal 500 bis 1000 keine
definierten obergrenzen brandenburg und
thüringen
alle gäste der feier in der oberpfalz
sollen ab morgen getestet werden um
herauszufinden wie viele sich
tatsächlich angesteckt haben die
ansteckungsgefahr in geschlossenen
räumen ist deutlich höher als im freien
in der zdf- heute- app erklären wir
warum und was man machen kann um das
risiko auch dort so weit wie möglich zu
verringern
über die tester an bayerns autobahnen
werden inzwischen weitere details
bekannt so wusste gesundheitsministerin
melanie huml csu deutlich früher vom
ausmaß des problems als sie bisher
behauptet hatte hummel hatte vergangenen
mittwoch berichtet dass zehntausende
reiserückkehrer vergeblich auf ihre
testergebnisse warteten sie hätte dies
erst am mittwochmorgen erfahren jetzt
allerdings bestätigte sie einen bericht
der süddeutschen zeitung wonach ihr
ministerium bereits am montag informiert
worden war
in frankreich soll es künftig eine
generelle masken pflicht am arbeitsplatz
geben außer jemand hat ein einzelbüro
überall sonst also auch in korridoren in
besprechungsräumen und auf freiflächen
werde die maske verpflichtend teilte das
arbeitsministerium mit
in frankreich steigt die zahl der neu
mit corona infizierten wieder schnell an
thomas walde hat mehr aus paris
schritt für schritt weitet frankreich
die masken pflicht aus auf den champs
élysées in paris gilt sie nun wie in 330
gemeinden des landes selbst beim joggen
das ist eine gute initiative um die
menschen zur verantwortung zu machen
weil man zu viele menschen sieht die
sich ohne maske versammeln
wir müssen uns an die regeln halten
bürger müssen sich zivil verhalten
nun kündigt die regierung an dass zum
ende der ferien selbst in den
unternehmen maske getragen werden muss
in sitzungsräumen auf den gängen einzige
ausnahme einzelbüros details würden noch
festgelegt
hier sehen wie sich die
gesundheitssituation verschlechtert vor
allem die haupt indikatoren in diesem
zusammenhang ist es wichtig die regeln
in den unternehmen anzupassen
die infektionszahlen im land steigen
mehr als 11.000 neue fälle in einer
woche selbst sonst sehr protest freudige
gewerkschaften haben dagegen die neuen
verschärfungen am arbeitsplatz wenig
einzuwenden
diese maßnahme macht sinn mittlerweile
ist nur dass sie ohne rücksprache mit
dem beschäftigten von oben herab
verordnet wird
foto rita gegen die verschärfungen regt
sich kaum widerstand das land ist
traumatisiert auf dem höhepunkt der
krise standen die krankenhäuser kurz vor
dem scheitern
das will frankreich kein zweites mal
erleben sagt unser korrespondent in
paris so viel zum thema corona geht
wählen als ob euer leben davon abhängt
sagt michelle obama in einer emotionalen
rede zum start des parteitags der
us-demokraten es ist ein parteitag wie
es ihn noch nie gab wegen corona digital
video konferenz statt mega-event
botschaften an die wähler hatten die
demokraten dennoch alle mit dem einen
ziel joe biden soll rein ins weiße haus
vor allem aber soll donald trump dort
aus ziehen nach der wahl anfang november
aus den usa eines traums
die nationalhymne auch sie kommt als
videoclip daher dieser parteitag der
demokraten findet im internet statt
wegen corona zusammengeschrumpft auf
eine große video inszenierung
der act national convention moderatorin
eva longoria schaltet in die ganze
nation zu bürgern und promis
geschlossenheit wollen die demokraten
demonstrieren auch parteilinke sollen
das eher moderate team joe biden und
kamera harris unterstützen appell von
bernie sanders und john gewählt wird ist
der ganze fortschritt den wir gemacht
haben in gefahr
auf der virtuellen bühne zeichnen die
demokraten das bild eines bunten und
vielfältigen amerikas der bruder von
george floyd der bei einem brutalen
polizeieinsatz getötet wurde ruft zu
einer schweigeminute auf in einer
aufgezeichneten rede übte michelle obama
vernichtende kritik kam donald trump
historisch dass eine ehemalige first
lady einen amtierenden präsidenten
scharf attackiert wann immer wir zu
diesem weißen haus schauen für führung
trost beständigkeit bekommen wir nur
chaos und spaltung und einen völligen
mangel an empathie ist der falsche
präsident für unser land
am morgen danach reagiert auf die kritik
ich wäre doch nicht hier im weißen haus
aber biden und barack obama haben einen
schlechten job gemacht hätten sie ihn
gut gemacht wäre ich heute nicht hier
es ist ein besonderer parteitag in
corona zeiten am donnerstag wird joe
biden seine nominierungs rede halten
auch zugeschaltet von zuhause 2005 traf
ein anschlag den libanon ins mark der
damalige ministerpräsident rafik hariri
wurde getötet viele libanesen gaben der
syrischen führung die schuld daran die
damals truppen im libanon stationiert
hatte
es folgt eine jahrelange internationale
untersuchung und heute verurteilt das
sondertribunal in den haag einen
libanesen allerdings in abwesenheit
er soll mitglied der pro syrischen
hisbollah sein
die richter sehen aber keinen beweis
dass die hisbollah führung oder syrien
den anschlag organisiert haben
durch die autobombe starben damals neben
hariri 21 weitere menschen mehr als 200
wurden verletzt
morgen gibt es einen sondergipfel der eu
zur aufgewühlten situation in belarus
heute warnt russland das ausland davor
sich einzumischen
das könnte die lage weiter eskalieren
sagt der kreml in belarus auch heute
wieder proteste und streiks in
staatsbetrieben die opposition bildet
jetzt mit vertretern der
zivilgesellschaft einen sogenannten
koordinierungsrat das ziel ein
friedlicher machtwechsel und jetzt so
ein thema das in deutschland heftig
diskutiert wird das sind einsätze der
polizei die offenbar aus dem ruder
gelaufen sind immer mehr handy videos
gibt es davon aus mehreren städten sind
das alles einzelfälle oder hat die
polizei ein generelles gewaltproblem in
ihren reihen
und wie reagiert die politik zu seiner
santana hat recherchiert
das handy video das in den sozialen
netzwerken verbreitet wird ist eindeutig
ein polizist tritt mit voller wucht
mehrfach auf einen am boden liegenden
mann
diese szenen spielten sich am samstag
nacht in frankfurt sachsenhausen ab und
haben heute auch den hessischen
innenminister auf den plan gerufen
das ist völlig inakzeptabel und ist mit
den werten der hessischen polizei in
keiner weise in einklang zu bringen
es hat direkt vor ort haben die kollegen
auf ihn eingewirkt und es sind sofort
disziplinarrechtliche maßnahmen auch
eröffnet worden
die polizei frankfurt sagt dass die
kollegen vorher beleidigt und angespuckt
worden sein nachdem sie einer
alkoholisierten gruppe platzverweise
erteilt hatten zu der auch der
betroffene 29-jährige gehörte auch in
düsseldorf kam es am wochenende zu einem
umstrittenen polizeieinsatz ein beamter
kniet auf hals oder kopf eines am boden
liegenden 15 jährigen
hat die polizei ein strukturelles
problem ja glaubt thomas müller der
lange selbst als polizist gearbeitet hat
ich glaube das große problem nicht darin
dass polizeibeamte ja immer in
schwierigen negativen situationen
arbeiten und das auch spuren hinterlässt
also die berufliche wirklichkeit
hinterlässt spuren bei ihnen fördert
vorurteile stereotypen und das kann zu
fehlverhalten gerade bei kontrollen
führen
auch das verhalten der polizei in
ingelheim am wochenende wirft fragen auf
menschen die gegen einen aufmarsch von
rechten demonstrieren wollten werden
trotz corona gefahr in einen tunnel
gedrängt und dann sprühen die beamten
pfefferspray innenminister lewentz will
auch diesen polizeieinsatz nun genau
untersuchen lassen und jetzt zu einem
arbeitstreffen der kanzlerin eigentlich
aber dann doch mehr
es geht um den besuch bei
nrw-ministerpräsident armin laschet der
villa merkels nachfolge als parteichef
werden
als kanzlerkandidat der union wird auch
csu chef markus söder gehandelt und der
hatte merkel im juli so empfangen im
prunkvollen schloss am chiemsee
inklusive kutschfahrt und schiffstour
vor alpenkulisse jetzt ist lascher dran
rhein-ruhr eher gefährdet als golden
dort ferber es ist ein besuch bei dem es
um schöne bilder geht die gibt es auch
trotz pandemie nur die geräuschkulisse
wird dominiert von ein paar
demonstranten braunkohle gegner
lautstark und auf abstand
angela merkel trifft in düsseldorf an
historischer stätte armin laschet und
sein landeskabinett im ständehaus einst
parlament heute kunstmuseum sprechen wir
über corona europa und das ruhrgebiet
das kanzlerkandidaten thema das wohl
auch anlass für den besuch ist steht
nicht auf der tagesordnung
für mich ist wichtig dass wir trotz der
spannungen rund um diese frage uns jetzt
nicht die ganzen monate nur mit
innerparteilichen dingen beschäftigen
wir haben alle beschrieben wie ernst die
korona situation ist rasches bilanz als
corona krisenmanager ist zugleich
wichtig für seine chancen auf den
cdu-vorsitz merkel lobt heute lasches
vorgehen masken im schulunterricht seien
im bevölkerungsreichen
nordrhein-westfalen richtig hohe
bußgelder ebenso viel einigkeit gibt es
in dieser pressekonferenz und eben die
frage ob da nicht merkels und
wunschnachfolger neben mir steht
ich habe für mich immer gesagt wer cdu
vorsitzende ist muss auch bereit sein
und natürlich auch fähig kanzler zu sein
armin laschet kandidiert und als
ministerpräsident von
nordrhein-westfalen bringt er viele
qualifikationen mit sich ansonsten werde
ich mich nicht einmischen aber das
rüstzeug für das kanzleramt bescheinigt
sie laschet mit dem sie im anschluss
nach essen zur historischen zeche
zollverein fährt der besucher nordrhein
westfalen deutlich anders als der in
bayern
man könne es auf unterschiedliche weise
schön machen sagt merkel bleibt moment
in der politik andreas kalbitz tritt
zurück der rechtsextreme politiker
verzichtet auf den vorsitz der afg
fraktion im potsdamer landtag bisher
hatte er das amt nur ruhen lassen bis
über seinen ausschluss aus der partei
entschieden ist
afg chef jörg beute nannte die
entscheidung gegenüber dem zdf
unvermeidbar und überfällig heute wurde
auch bekannt dass die staatsanwaltschaft
gegen kalbitz ermittelt eine merkwürdige
geschichte
er soll den kommissarischen afg
fraktionschef dennis hohloch
versehentlich heftig geschlagen haben
als er ihn begrüßen wollte wohl auch
liegt seither mit einem milzriss
im krankenhaus schlechte nachrichten
heute von den landwirten in deutschland
die erntebilanz macht ihnen sorgen in
diesem jahr wurden etwas mehr als 42
millionen tonnen getreide geerntet das
sind knapp fünf prozent weniger als der
durchschnitt der vergangenen jahre
ein hauptgrund die anhaltende
trockenheit jetzt was ganz anderes mit
viel multimedia und kunst meldet sich
ein wichtiges museum in berlin zurück
und zwar spektakulär in einer neuen
dauerausstellung das jüdische museum ist
ein publikumsmagnet und ein ort an dem
sich jüdische geschichte und kultur in
deutschland erleben lassen
zweieinhalb jahre lang war das jüdische
museum das größte seiner art in europa
für den umbau geschlossen bis heute
chris hat apple ein hauch von woodstock
im jüdischen museum trommeln für einen
neuanfang
der israelische künstler gila trat man
mit einer videoinstallation aus einem
stillgelegten saarländischen bergwerk
er nennt sein werk trotz zwei
schlagzeuger ein rhythmus harmonie und
dissonanzen
so sieht er das heutige deutsch
israelische verhältnis
ich wollte etwas über die zwei seelen in
unserer brust sagen als es heißt deutsch
und jüdisch zu sein
zweieinhalb jahre wurde amt neustadt
gearbeitet
es hat sich gelohnt nur ein beispiel
familienalben auf einem riesigen
touchscreen 400 objekte spuren jüdischen
lebens von der original thora der
heiligen schrift bis zum geretteten
teddy aus einem der kindertransporte von
ein schwerpunkt ist der neuanfang nach
der nazi katastrophe jüdische mitbürger
erzählen über ihren alltag in
deutschland
wir sind kein holocaust museum betont
die neue holländische museumschefin
mein wunsch ist dass es viele
hunderttausende besucher geben wie er
die ins museum kommen und dass sie hier
die lebendigkeit und reichtum des
jüdisches leben spüren
30 millionen euro die sich der bund die
neue ausstellung kosten gut investiertes
geld gegen antisemitismus so monika
grütters ich bin zuversichtlich dass
auch die neue dauerausstellung des
jüdischen museums berlin zur warnen
erinnerung an antisemitische ausgrenzung
und verfolgung beiträgt das comeback des
jüdischen museums in berlin
das haus mit der außergewöhnlichen
architektur jetzt die chance jüdisches
leben neu zu entdecken
ab kommenden sonntag für alle geöffnet
geschichte der juden hat sich nicht
geändert aber unsere perspektive darauf
sagt die museumsdirektorin und jetzt
hier in der 19 uhr heute sendung der
sport rudi ja eine spannende fußball
woche haben wir bayern münchen hat
morgen die chance in lissabon ins
champions league finale einzuziehen
rb leipzig heute abend das team von
trainer julian nagelsmann muss gegen den
französischen serienmeister paris st
germain antreten und brennt darauf
erstmals das finale der königsklasse zu
erreichen
sie wollen weiter champions league
geschichte schreiben eine letzte
aktivierung der leipziger heute morgen
in estoril zwar mit respekt vor dem
namhaften gegner aber auch im vertrauen
auf die eigene stärke ich glaube dass
wir ihnen wehtun können im eigenen
ballbesitz dass wir mehr tun können wenn
wir stabil sind im letzten drittel mit
dem ball am fuß schon der
viertelfinalsieg gegen atletico madrid
bedeutet den größten erfolg der
vereinsgeschichte jetzt kommt es zum
packenden deutschen trainerduell
zwischen julian nagelsmann und thomas
tuchel und der pariser coach schwärmt
selbstbewusst von der aktuellen form
seines starensembles um nena und auf dem
höchsten niveau im kopf hoch
konzentriert stets mit einem lächeln auf
den lippen und mit viel viel qualität
wir sind absolut bereit fürs erste
deutsch-französische duell heute in
lissabon und claudia neumann steht vor
dem teamhotel in lissabon claudia wie
schätzt du die chancen von leipzig ein
ganz ehrlich fifty fifty für mich ist
das eine ganz offene partie heute abend
klar paris verfügt über die individuelle
klasse aber leipzig hat im viertelfinale
aus meiner sicht deutlich mehr überzeugt
vor wenigen minuten ist die mannschaft
hier in estoril abgefahren richtung
stadion richtung stadt und das ist für
alle der vorläufige höhepunkt ihrer noch
relativ jungen karriere wer mal
nachgeschaut nur patrick schickt die
leihgabe aus rom hat halbfinale
champions-league-halbfinale erfahrungen
damals vor zwei jahren knapp verloren
gegen liverpool
ob er allerdings anders als im
viertelfinale heute von beginn an ran
darf das ist noch offen
vielen dank claudia neumann für die
einschätzung für das spiel heute abend
in der europa league greift inter
mailand nach dem ersten internationalen
titel seit 2010 im halbfinale
deklassieren die italiener den
ukrainischen meister donezk mit
zu null eine imposante tor gala in
düsseldorf
romelu lukaku der erste spieler der in
zehn aufeinander folgenden europa league
spielen getroffen hat doch bevor der
belgische nationalstürmer dran war
erzielten gegen schachtjor donetsk erst
einmal andere tore für inter mailand
nach flanke von varela tritt martinez
zur 1 0 halbzeitführung für den
italienischen meisterschaftszweiten nach
zwei weiteren treffern zum 13 0 durch
d'ambrosio und erneut martinez schlagen
die fünf eindrucksvollen minuten von
top-torjäger lukaku nach einem 14 0 in
der 78 minute erhöhte er in der 83
zum 5 0-endstand für inter als habe er
sich nur noch rasch warm schließen
wollen fürs finale gegen sevilla und das
war der sport christian vielen dank
morgen wird ein tag zum durchatmen
wettermäßig fast keine gewitter mehr
hitze und schwüle sind auch passé freuen
sie sich also auf die details gleich mit
katja honnefer heute-journal zeit 21 45
mit der kollegin marietta slomka von uns
war es dass wir heute gerne bis morgen
aber erst in einen angenehmen
dienstagabend
[Musik]
meine damen und herren morgen kommt hoch
frederik damit werden die letzten
regenschauer und gewitter deutschland
richtung osten verlassen
aber es ist nur ein kleines zwischenhoch
denn sie sehen hier schon über
frankreich über dem ärmelkanal und
großbritannien da kommen schon wieder
die nächsten schauer und gewitter heran
schauer und gewitter gibt es auch noch
in dieser nacht zwischen der ostseeküste
und im spreewald und auch aus den alpen
heraus sonst bildet sich auch mal nebel
und die temperaturen sinken auf werte
zwischen 18 grad an der ostsee und elf
grad am alpenrand und morgen erwarten
uns dann höchst temperaturen von 22 grad
an den alpen und bis zu 28 grad an
mittel- oder am niederrhein am vormittag
keine es noch einige gewitter geben im
äußersten osten deutschlands die ziehen
dann aber im laufe des tages ab in
berlin kann das vielleicht noch bis
mittags dauern bis da die letzten
schauer abgezogen sind sonst gibt es
viel sonnenschein und das gilt auch für
süddeutschland da kann es vielleicht am
vormittag aus den alpen heraus noch mal
ein bisschen gewittern und sonst ziehen
diese schau aber über die donau und in
den nächsten tagen wird es noch mal sehr
heiß die temperaturen steigen bis 34
grad am donnerstag bis 37 grad am
freitag und dann wird's wieder
gewittriger schönen abend noch